All right guys, so here is an example for the weekly bias. I'm looking at AUDUSD on the weekly time frame of course
So right here you can see price took out the extended liquidity, which is a high over here
Where is the fair valley gap? The fair valley gap is right around here. Is it in the?
Discount it is not so what you can do when the fair valley gap is not in the discount you can use the fib
right
From the freewhelly gap starting candle to the ending candle and the 0.5 level is gonna be your drawn liquidity
Cool so that the 0.5 level of this freewhelly gap is gonna be a drawn liquidy because if you draw a refer bonacci from bottom to top
You can see that
Okay, actually the 0.5 level is here. So
This right here could be our target right there
draw on liquidity
Okay, so now let's since we have taken out extended liquidity. Let's go to
Actually, I would only look to target this level because that is the fair valley gap
So I don't want to like, you know hold risk for my bias or for my entry
You just got to play like that. So we took out the external liquidity on the weekly. Let's drop down remember from weekly
we go to the for our time frame and
And
Over here, what do you see? We took out the extended liquidity here now?
We're simply waiting for a market structure shift. So what do we get here?
We have a higher high higher low and a higher high
Annotated by the indicator and that in this indicator is a game changer. Okay, so right here
What we see we have this freck the low here and
Price took out the low. So now what do we have here once we take out the low?
We have this very valley gap and we also have this auto block this bullish candle that took out liquidity here, right?
so right here this could have been your entry and
Simply you could have gone for stop over here and the original target which was somewhere around here, right?
Let me see
What was the original starting point of the fairly gap? Okay, this is right here cool
So right here, you can see we got our entry and let's see how this plays out
Beautiful and also you can see the the 0.5 level was also hit
so
Yeah, that's pretty much it guys for the weekly bus. However, as I've said before you could have looked for multiple entries
by using the
Smaller top frame which would have been the 15 minute time frame and but I'll get to that later in the video
So don't worry about it. Okay
But this right here is a bread and butter model button. Oh my god, I can't pronounce burger bread and butter model guys
Okay, you can only have two time frames and look for this
but
Generally, I would be honest with you. I like the three time frames and as I said before I'm gonna teach you that
Later on in the course. So let's move on to the daily example now